je vis bonjour jours heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur le plateau de la
matinale de france alors protéger les
policiers alors qu'ils sont eux-mêmes
censée protéger les citoyens un dilemme
pour l'exécutif s'agissant de la
protection des citoyens tout d'abord est
elle suffisamment bien assurée je crois
que la protection des citoyens et est
insuffisante il ya de nombreux trous
dans la raquette si l'on peut dire il
suffirait de rappeler les violences
conjugales
les violences sur mineurs en particulier
sur sur les enfants
donc on est quand même dans un climat
d'insécurité avec des prises en charge
notamment policières qui sont pas
toujours la hauteur à la hauteur des
enjeux on sait la difficulté évidemment
pour les victimes de faire enregistrer
parfois leurs plaintes dans l'est dans
les commissariats donc qu'il ya encore
du travail du travail à faire alors
maintenant
par rapport à cet épisode 2 de tags
appelant au meurtre ou mutilation
policière bon c'est la haine envers la
police mais c'est pas nouveau il
suffirait de rappeler le film de mathieu
kassovitz en 1995 donc il ya déjà plus
de 25 ans qui portait justement ce titre
de la haine voilà alors on sait que
s'agissant notamment des rapports avec
les jeunes c'est très compliqué très
compliqué depuis longtemps bon il est
évident que là il ya quand même une
escalade on peut pas nier le fait qu'il
ya des policiers qui sont insultés qui
sont menacés donc y compris y compris de
demain aujourd'hui tant kia il ya une
dégradation encore une fois des des
relations à celle sont les relations qui
sont aujourd'hui elle même agressé un
dans tout ce qu'elle pouvait compter
contenir de de règlement pacifique voilà
on n'est pas d'accord mais malgré tout
effectivement c'est autour d'une table
pour évoquer les problèmes ensemble
voilà alors par contre pour la question
effectivement de la protection
arriverait presque à penser qu'ils
pourraient aujourd'hui escorter les
policiers comme parfois les policiers
escortent les pompiers pour faire leur
travail cette question est absolument
aberrante moi je pense qu'il faut
effectivement plus deux policiers sur le
terrain en immersion dans le terrain il
faut des policiers probablement mieux
formés avec peut-être aussi plus de
maturité je pense que le l'âge de
présentation au concours de gardien de
la paix est trop tôt qui sait
qu'aujourd'hui à 17 ans on peut se
présenter au concours de gardien de la
paix moi je pense qu'on ne devrait pas
avoir sur le terrain d'hommes et de
femmes qui sont âgés de moins de 30 ans
il faut quand même une expérience pour
exercer une fonction qui est une
fonction quand même d'autorité on parle
aujourd'hui de la haine envers la police
d'agressions de policiers est ce qu'il
faut s'en sont inquiétées est générale
alors il faut pas généraliser de même
que les violences policières sont pas
des violents systémique un de toute
l'institution policière un bond de même
il n'ya pas de haine systémique à
l'encontre des policiers alors là aussi
il ya l'effet loupe médiatique un
qu'évidemment en corée de campagne
présidentielle en plus en plus sur fond
de campagne présidentielle donc
évidemment c'est alimente le thème de la
sécurité et de l'insécurité il ne reste
pas beaucoup de temps michel fize je
voudrais vous poser une dernière
question quand même comment est-ce qu'on
peut concilier la protection des
citoyens justement et la protection des
policiers je crois qu'il faut rappeler
que les policiers sont des citoyens
comme les autres donc ils doivent être
protégés comme les autres citoyens ni
plus ni moins maintenant évidemment il
faut leur permettre de faire leur
travail en bonne condition en étant
mieux équipés mieux mieux protégés du
point de vue du point de vue matériel
merci beaucoup michel l'édito de michel
fize à retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux